i think the big thing about the game hey
the arizona cardinals gave them a lot of
credit for hanging around doing all
those type of things i still can sit
here after watching the film yesterday
where i like them but i don't know if
i'm a total believer in them quite yet
like where i'm just going oh they're
definitely going to make the playoffs
and being like i understand they're in
playoff contention and they're in that
conversation and all those type of
things but
i still look at the offense as being way
too much on one guy and kyla murray i
don't know if it delivers enough as far
as scheme-wise all the time
there's so much pressure on him mike
just to be hey quick throw make the
great throw okay the the scheme itself
can be kind of simple at times and then
it comes on to him running and making
plays and doing that way and yes it's
good but seattle's defense stinks and he
was able to pull that off more maybe
against the seahawks than he would be
able to against some other teams that
are out there
but he still does it every week that's
the thing he doesn't do it every week he
didn't do it against carolina and he
didn't do it against detroit and they're
not that good but they have formulas to
stop that offense he's still awesome and
you have to worry about that and
seattle's always gonna have an issue
with him for sure sorry and and you know
i think of the seahawks they still wear
the same uniforms
but the defense is very different than
what it was especially up front why in
the world can't they get a pass rush and
everything griffin reportedly available
dallas cowboys looking to move on cut
their losses i i can't imagine why the
seahawks wouldn't be at the front of the
line to find anyone who can help that
pass rush yeah i mean yes but you know
again everson griffin hasn't looked that
great either so i don't know you know
two and a half sacks this year you know
yeah well i mean everybody's dropping
back to throw against dallas so yeah i'm
sure he does at some point i mean it's
drop back and throw for 50 yards every
time you drop back but
the defensive line to your pick your
question and all that i mean as you know
we've talked about it it's they're
they're not good they stink that's all
there is to it the defense in general
stinks it's not coached well they can't
play man-to-man and they can't rush the
passer and then what comes worse in a
game like this with arizona because of
kyla murray's ability to run and do
things like that they were reluctant to
blitz
and they just played zones and try to
rally to him and make the tackle so all
their eyes are on him and all those
things but what he does is he wears you
out like a derrick henry like in the
fourth quarter kyla murray has the same
effect but it's more because you've been
chasing this damn guy all over the field
and then the pass rush starts to wear
out as the game goes along because
you're always oh is he this way how is
he that way oh he's going that way let
me chase him and it just it exhausts
defenses to where it's a very unique way
that he wears them down because of his
skill set
but generally this seahawks the seahawks
defense i mean yeah i i one of the
reasons you and i both are now at the
point where we regard the buccaneers as
the better
team in the conference that defense
is is not going you know they they live
dangerously and they feel like they can
win every game right you're eventually
going to get into a playoff game where
it's not going to go your way because
your defense isn't going to be able to
step up and this is as glaring as it's
ever been for the seahawks yeah it is
it's it is glaring and you know what
they're they need jamal adams back
um
they've been relying on
yeah our defense isn't good
but we'll make two or three plays just
to give russell wilson an extra
possession and they did that in the game
i mean they caused some
some issues you know deandre hopkins
fumble they did intercept kyler murray
right i mean they they were there it was
there to be had as far as that's
concerned and let's not forget this
aspect again too
you know the seahawks got the two worst
penalties of the day called on them it's
2717 the cardinals are backed up it's
third and five they're down on their own
like 12 yard line he throws that ball
over the middle that's a bang bang play
and they caught unnecessary roughness on
bobby wagner that collinsworth
and terry mccauley didn't agree with
that was a huge moment because they're
going to punt the ball to seattle who's
going to get the ball around midfield
and they're up 10 and that's where
seattle thrives to go okay now we're up
17 or you know 17 or 13 or whatever it
is so that really killed them and then
let's not forget the
the jump over on the field gold call
like with benson mayo that was a huge
that was a huge call the leverage call
that ended up letting the cardinals
score the touchdown so they had some
moments of stopping them or doing that
but you know they got a little unlucky
that way too
and you know it felt at times like the
seahawks were just gonna bust it wide
open and the cardinals would have no
chance one of the things that helped the
cardinals
three interceptions from russell wilson
now can you rank
the from from most egregious to least
egregious the mistakes the miscues from
the guy who was the mvp favorite who may
not be now well yeah i mean there's
there's a lot on him all the time too i
think that last one i think is probably
takes the cake just because that was
great defense by vance joseph the last
the last four plays of the game were all
out blitz
all out blitz
the dk metcalf touchdown screen that got
called back and then vance joseph went
to
let's show that all out blitz that i did
and lets everybody drop and russell
wilson they did this to him two or three
times during the game this was the last
time of course and he i guess he
predetermined and thought they were
blitzing he was going to dump it off so
that was a bad one you know the
interception in the end zone of course
another bad one where they they're
trying to run a quick play and the
cardinals are not
not lined up properly they mess up
coverages buddha baker i don't even
think he's supposed to cover chris
carson on the flat and he makes that
play russell wilson thought he had a
slam dunk touchdown that's why he threw
the ball he was like oh he's so wide
open let me just throw a little easy one
and then i would say the third one
with dk metcalf again vance joseph all
out blitz forces russell wilson to run
to the right and dk metcalf i think was
running down field and he thought wait
let me stop and come back and help my
wide quarterback and as he stopped
russell was already in the motion he
threw the jump ball to him and that's
where patrick peterson got the
interception they were off
off all night dk and russell uh it was
as off as i've seen them be in a game so
far
what do you think caused that i mean it
you could look at it and say they didn't
do enough to get dk metcalf involved do
you think that the cardinals
after taking a closer look at it
specifically took away dk met well i got
to give patrick peterson some credit he
did do a really good job they matched
him up on dk metcalf a lot
the biggest thing is i think the first
thing you said
you know it doesn't matter man-to-man
whatever you got to have some place for
dk metcalf just to get the ball and get
his beak wet a little right just like
get him going get him in the game that
was unfair to him and then the other
thing is i'm gonna place the blame on
russell wilson i am you can't let
defenses play dk metcalf man to man one
on one there was a handful of plays
where they're playing man-to-man on dk
metcalf and russell wilson goes to the
other side of the field and you're going
whoa dk metcalf just blew by patrick
peterson it's a 50-yard touchdown if he
throws it or whoa
patrick peterson's 15 yards off just
throw the six yard hitch route to dk
metcalf let's see if they could tackle
him you know so i really think that was
more on russell to he's got to like i
don't know he usually always does it
reprogram his brain to just go hey if
it's man-to-man i'm throwing to him
nobody can cover my guy's better than
your guy i'm an awesome thrower and i
think sometimes that's all that needs to
be done with those two
yeah and and look
you can take away dk and they still have
tyler lockett and at some point they're
going to have josh gordon although
people are confused i was talking to
someone yesterday about this what in the
world is going on with josh gordon he
applied for reinstatement june 15
still waiting for a final decision from
the nfl but
you put gordon out there with those guys
and greg olsen still has the capacity to
get out then that offense can be very
very good
i just worry about the defense yes and i
worry about
you know a tough game big game division
on the line one seat on the line
whatever the case may be
with or without jamal adams because i i
think there's only so much jamal adams
do right and and and he's got to be
especially after this loss even more
motivated to get back as soon as
possible and i hope he doesn't push it
to the point where he's got that groin
injury or just some sort of a nagging
problem where he's not completely 100
all year long chris no i that would that
would be horrible because you know like
we like we're talking about that
it doesn't look like they're going to
stop people that's just not gonna happen
you know again the talent's not good
enough the coaching's not good enough
right now you know there's there's too
many mistakes that way and yet they're
relying on
just hey pete carroll ken norton jr
let's hustle let's be tough and we'll
cause a little chaos every now and then
and make a play that way and like to
what you're saying yeah that's good but
i don't know if that's gonna get it done
against the really good teams in the nfc
playoff picture like are you gonna be
able to depend on drew brees or tom
brady you know and that team making a
stupid mistake uh in the third or fourth
quarter to do that no i wouldn't rely on
that so yeah i look at them and go pass
rusher
another corner something like that to
play man-to-man a little bit they gotta
look be looking in this trade market
right now to improve their team
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports